the Joe Rogan experience Obama endorsed
by Dhin I'm sold
are you oh yeah he's fine now
what's Obama endorsed him no you can't
remember anything do you see what a
Donald Trump jr. tweeted no already put
it on Instagram that Biden is is like a
web browser it's now it's a hilarious
mean the memes have just begun and here
we are
it's April but by the time November
rolls wrong I don't the that's debate
what is his mind is like a web browser
19 tabs are open 17 or frozen he has no
idea where the music is coming from this
world is just insane dude I I tweeted
something I was like I don't know people
gonna get pissed off at this or what but
I tweeted oh great
Bernie dropped out now the only thing
that needs happen is Trump and Biden
need to drop out and and I was like I
might get [ __ ] [ __ ] for this but I
didn't I care but I think this is I hit
everybody you know but like dude it was
just like the fact that we have these
options are just I don't know I'm a
[ __ ] idiot I'm not good politically
but yeah I'm neither I'm not good
politically either but it's just when
you see I just the debate Trump versus
Biden it's gonna be a mess we're just
gonna be there what are they talking
about Trump's press conference yesterday
I strive watched a bunch of him and I'm
like what am i doing like it's just he
seems like the negative attention it
just finally getting to him oh yeah oh I
saw the clip where he was like you're
nasty or whatever he was saying you're
disgrace to the to the reporter yeah he
was saying you're fake yeah he always
says the ratings are down I know things
are down you have no credibility yeah
that's his his thing has always go after
their ratings which is kind of funny it
is funny too because he was tweeting
about he was like I'm number one on
Facebook people under fault yeah people
reading that on their phones are dying
from Corona number one on Facebook what
do you say what even is that what
how long a minute
who's I know I know exactly number one
on Facebook is like I have the coldest
part of the ocean like what yes how are
you measuring that he said that his co
vid 19 his coronavirus reports had
higher ratings my finale of The Bachelor
that's so surreal I just can't be real
live it's so silly
it can't be real life the one thing
about Trump is whether you like him or
not he is funny oh he's a lair he is
funny
he's hilarious he's a funny guy he might
not be fit to be President he might be
one of those you know but who is forget
it whether you think he's fit to be
President or not fit to be President if
you deny the fact he's funny we have a
problem yeah that's that's that's it
that's that's where I'm at we can argue
whether or not he's doing a good job
anomaly or a bad job so try but guess
what yeah he's full of laughs that
[ __ ] time that he was talking about
buying Greenland he probably goes I
promised not to do this he had a photo
of a huge Trump Tower in the middle
agreement I didn't see that it's
literally that's funny it's laughs deep
out to out I was dying when he was like
wait did you see the press conference
where he was doing it was like yeah they
said I didn't do a good job but I did a
good job and this is the proof and he
shows this little piece of apron he goes
like this so you know that they were
lying and he flicks the papers [ __ ]
lunatics lunatic it's not what you would
expect right no I expect a person to be
like Obama or like Clinton or whoever to
be presidential like Bush you don't
respect that what I thought but that's
what I thought Bush was I thought Bush
was the guy that everyone was like
finally a regular guy like me a regular
guy and I was like okay it'll be a while
till that happens again yeah and it came
back I mean Trump's like he's like the
guy in your family were like oh he's
coming to Thanksgiving like this mother
is gonna be talking the whole time and
then you find out he's president is
Greenland I promise not to do this
degree let just one gigantic Trump Tower
this is a Trump in the middle of
Greenland with the explanation excellent
exclamation point
yes come on that's [ __ ] funny that's
funny he like retweets memes and [ __ ]
weird but also like look at the doctor
behind him with the short with the shawl
just when he does his face oh just like
what is happening look at look at why am
i here okay oh so funny she's got the
same look like as if someone farted and
she's not gonna say anything but she
smells it really felt good she does and
she's always wearing that those capes
she does wear a lot of capes yeah
[Applause]